bonjour à tous suite cet après-midi de
l'examen du budget 2011 par mission
l'état l'a annoncé l'heure est à la
maîtrise des finances et les
collectivités vont en subir les
conséquences
les dotations de l'état aux
collectivités territoriales vont en
effet être gelée pendant trois ans à 59
milliards d'euros et au sein de ce
budget les crédits affectés aux
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales vont subir une baisse de
3,8 pour cent à 2 5 milliards d'euros
depuis la réforme des collectivités
territoriales les élus ne décolère pas
nicolas sarkozy a beau justifier sa
d'austérité budgétaire à laquelle les
maires doivent faire face eh bien ils ne
sont pas d'accord et ils sont très
inquiets puisque depuis la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle ils ont très
peu de visibilité sur leurs ressources
fiscales
nul doute que ce problème a va revenir
sur le devant de la scène lors de
l'examen cet après-midi du budget tout
de suite donc direction l'hémicycle très
bonne séance
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi de finances
pour 2011 adopté par l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat va examiner les
crédits d'émission relations avec les
collectivités territoriales et les
articles 79 à 86 puis nous examinerons
le compte spécial avant ce collectivités
territoriales et dans notre discussion
la parole est à monsieur pierre jarlier
rapporteur spécial de la commission des
finances
vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur spécial
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la mission
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales qui regroupe les concours
financiers de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales inscrits en dotations
budgétaires et les moyens la direction
générale des collectivités locales
représentent 2,5 milliards d'euros dans
une enveloppe des concours de l'état de
59 milliards d'euros et même de 99 me
hier si l'on ajoute la fiscalité de
transférer et dégrèvements vous pouvez
constater que je me garde bien employer
des termes d'effort financier de l'état
que notre assemblée a banni à l'occasion
du vote de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques 2011 2014 pour les
remplacer par ceux de concours
financiers de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales sur les crédits même de la
mission
la commission des finances un peu
d'observation a présenté en effet la
plupart des dotations retracé par la
mission rct se voient appliquer la règle
du gel en valeur des concours financiers
de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales
il s'agit en particulier la dotation
forfaitaire titres sécurisés
la dotation de développement urbain
d'aidé uda dotation d'équipement des
territoires ruraux detr dont on parlera
de la dotation régisseur de police
municipale et de la dotation globale
d'équipement des départements pour la
dotation générale de décentralisation
qui sont calculées sur le calcul des
charges transférées quelques ajustements
mineurs sont prévues on note aussi que
les dotations outre mer qui obéissent à
des règles d'indexation spécifique
échappe de fait à la règle de gel en
valeur
c'est le cas en particulier de la
dotation spéciale de construction et
d'équipement des établissements
scolaires à mayotte pour ce qui est des
crédits de fonctionnement de la
direction générale des collectivités
locales
on observe une forte hausse des moyens
en autorisations d'engagement qui
correspond notamment à une progression
des dépenses d'informatique en faveur du
projet colbert départementale on attend
beaucoup de cet outil pour la qualité
des échanges de données entre les
préfectures et la dgcl notamment lors de
la répartition de la dgf saisissant de
la péréquation
votre commission vous proposera
d'adopter un amendement qui crée dans le
prolongement d'un groupe de travail du
cfl une dsr cible pour soutenir
particulièrement les dix mille communes
les plus pauvres sans pénaliser les
autres et dans le même esprit que la dsi
cibles actuelles
l'examen du compte avant ce
collectivités territoriales appelle deux
observations et convient de signaler
d'abord que la très forte augmentation
des montants en cause est due au fait qu
en 2011
le compte de concours financier
retracera les reversements de recettes
de cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises de cotisation foncière des
entreprises d'imposition forfaitaire sur
les entreprises de réseaux et de taxe
sur les surfaces commerciales
alors qu'ils n'avaient plus à retracer
les reversements de taxe professionnelle
en 2010 nous revenons donc à un niveau
habituel
seconde observation la première section
du conte qui retrace les avances
accordées aux collectivités locales est
depuis longtemps très peu active
votre commission vous proposera un
amendement de suppression de ces crédits
sourire de ses observations la
commission des finances vous repose
adopté les crédits de la mission
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales et du concours financier
avances aux collectivités territoriales
en conclusion je voudrais évoquer ce qui
me paraît être une caractéristique
centrale du projet de budget 2011 pour
la mission et qui apparaît surtout à
travers les articles rattachés
il s'agit de la question du rôle et de
la place du comité des finances locales
cette instance de concertation et de
décision qui rassemble les collectivités
et l'état
et surtout qui a fait les preuves de sa
compétence et de son efficacité
fondamentalement le gel des dotations et
le fait que la préservation des éléments
de péréquation est désormais inscrite
dans la loi qui fixe elle même les
montants des diverses composantes de la
dgf des collectivités ces deux éléments
donc prive le cfl d'une grande part de
ses compétences or je crois profondément
nécessaire de préserver cette instance
de concertation entre l'état les
collectivités qui permet de progresser
et d'aboutir sur des sujets importants
je pense notamment aux groupes de
travail qui ont été constitués sur la ds
eu ou encore sur la dsr nous allons en
reparler tout à l'heure il nous faudra
donc restaurer à son profit des marges
de manoeuvre dans un contexte moins
favorable que la période passée durant
laquelle le cfl était amené à répartir
la progression des encours de l'état ses
marges de manoeuvre le cfl pour aller
retrouver d'une part en procédant aux
ajustements des dotations en fonction
des critères territoriaux et d'autre
part en participant à la définition des
règles de la péréquation horizontale
péréquation horizontale qui est un sujet
central dans un contexte de gel des
dotations de l'état aux collectivités
sur un site web
sur monsieur le rapporteur spécial
la parole est maintenant à monsieur
bernard saugey rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des lois avait la parole
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans le
bref laps de temps qui m'est imparti
pour évoquer devant vous les relations
financières entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales
je développerai trois thèmes qui ont
particulièrement retenu l'attention de
la commission des lois
premièrement votre commission a noté que
les collectivités seraient soumises en
1° inédit de modération budgétaire une
part importante des concours de l'état
fera l'objet d'un gel en valeur à
hauteur du montant ouvert en loi de
finances initiale pour 2010
cette association des acteurs locaux à
l'effort de lutte contre les déficits
publics
s'il a été accepté et compris bien
entendu par la commission a suscité
certaines remarques
tout d'abord je rappelle que les
collectivités sont loin d'être les
premières responsables de la dégradation
de nos finances publiques
merci au 31 décembre 2009 la dette
locale ne représentait que 10 et demi
pour cent de la dette publique totale
dès lors reed et que le gel serait une
garantie de non-baisse comme on dit
selon les termes employés par le
gouvernement et qu'il serait finalement
un facteur de protection des finances
locales nous semble pour le moins
contestable ensuite la limitation de la
croissance des concours de l'état vient
s'ajouter aux réformes déjà menées et
notamment au remplacement de la taxe
professionnelle par la contribution
économique territoriale qui a très
sensiblement réduit l'autonomie fiscale
des collectivités
celles ci sont donc de plus en plus
dépendante des décisions prises au
niveau central
or le pouvoir central n'est pas
forcément un donneur d'ordres facile à
vivre
l'état donne toujours plus de
responsabilités aux collectivités mais
quelquefois moins de
rien enfin votre commission s'est
inquiétée d'une autre mesure qui doit
favoriser la diminution des dépenses des
collectivités il s'agit de la modulation
des dotations de l'état en fonction de
critères dits de bonne gestion
votre commission est réservé voire
perplexe devant ce projet comment
sera-t-il possible de définir des
critères de bonne gestion qui soit
valable pour toutes les collectivités
indépendamment de leurs caractéristiques
en quoi ce projet s'inscrit il dans la
promotion du principe constitutionnel de
libre administration et pourquoi l'état
serait-il mieux placé que les élus
locaux pour distinguer ce qui relève
d'une gestion vertueuse et performante
de ceux qui à linverse est source de
gadji bref nous nous interrogeons sur la
légitimité de cette réforme qui en
l'état ne nous semble ni opportune ni
juste deuxièmement la commission pas
tout à fait deuxièmement la commission
des lois s'est intéressé de près à
l'état des finances départementales
en effet la crise de 2008 2009 a révélé
la fragilité structurelle des
départements qui sont soumis à un fort
effet de ciseaux et qui doivent
évidemment supporter les coûts induits
par le financement des dépenses sociales
celles ci représentent désormais 60 2%
de leurs charges de fonctionnement
dans ce cadre votre commission des lois
a pris acte de la création de la mission
d'appui chargée de venir en aide aux
départements les plus en difficulté et
dans le parlement sera amené à débattre
lors de l'examen du plf fr 2 du plf fr
pour 2010 elle a également noté que la
réforme de la dépendance permettrait
certainement d'apporter une réponse aux
problèmes rencontrés par les
départements dans le financement de la
p1 toutefois votre commission estime que
ces initiatives ne saurait à elle seule
resterait la viabilité des finances de
département elle considère ainsi qu'il
sera nécessaire à terme de revoir les
modalités de financement de toutes les
prestations sociales portées par les
départements afin soit d'augmenter le
taux de couverture des dépenses sociales
par l'état
soit de revoir les mécanismes de
fixation du montant du droit à
compensation en dernier lieu
je voudrais dire quelques mots sur la
participation des collectivités
territoriales au processus normatif tout
d'abord je tiens à saluer l'action de la
commission consultative d'évaluation des
normes qui a rempli ses missions de
manière exigeante et constructive et qui
a examiné pas moins de 108 texte en
jambes de janvier à septembre de cette
année plus généralement votre commission
a constaté que le gouvernement avait
fait certains efforts pour prendre mieux
en compte l'impact des normes sur les
collectivités territoriales ainsi un
processus de révision des normes a été
lancée en lien étroit avec les
associations d'élus et un moratoire sur
les normes nouvelles a été mise en place
par une circulaire de juillet dernier
pour soulager les acteurs locaux qui
sont trop souvent étouffés par les
normes techniques édictées par l'état
s'il est trop tôt pour juger de
l'efficacité concrète de ces mesures
elle démontre toutefois que les
mentalités sont en train de changer au
niveau central
telles sont les observations que votre
commission des lois voulait porter à la
connaissance du sénat et soul bénéfices
desquels elle a cependant donné l'avis
favorable à l'adoption des crédits de la
mission relations avec les collectivités
territoriales et du compte de concours
financier avances aux collectivités
territoriales sauvé merci monsieur
rapporteur je vais maintenant passer la
part notamment de collègues je vais
rappeler que le temps de parole
attribuée à chaque groupe pour chaque
discussion qu'on prend le temps
d'intervention et celui de l'explication
de vote
je vous rappelle qu'en application des
décisions mais conférence des présidents
aucune intervention des orateurs des
groupes de doit dépasser 10 minutes et
je rappelle aussi au gouvernement qu'il
a au total quinze minutes pour
intervenir
je souhaite j'aurai l'occasion demain
conférence des présidents quarante
propositions et j'aurais vous faire
constater que nous avons beaucoup de
difficultés à tenir
actuellement donc demandé à chacun
d'aller à l'essentiel
la parole est maintenant madame josiane
mathon-poinat pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen
sénateur du parti de gauche et la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
quelques mois après la réforme
territoriale et après la suppression de
la taxe professionnelle
le budget de cette mission que vous nous
soumettez l'occasion de porter à nouveau
un regard d'ensemble sur la place
on était à cordes collectivités
territoriales et le constat est alarmant
les entraves répétées réforme après
réforme au principe constitutionnel de
libre administration des collectivités
seront aujourd'hui à tel point ressentir
que l'atteinte l équilibre budgétaire de
nos collectivités centres ont fortement
et inéluctablement menacé plusieurs fois
nous amène à ce constat en premier lieu
il nous est annoncé qu entre 2011 et
2014 les concours de l'état feront
l'objet d'un gel en valeur à hauteur du
montant ouvert en loi de finances
initiale pour 2010 soit 52 45 milliards
d'euros
ce gel annonce une baisse d'au moins un
milliard d'euros des concours de l'état
pour 20000 commune et ceci ne signifie
rien d'autre qu'une asphyxie de nos
régions de nos départements de notre
commune alors que dans le même temps
l'état continue de se désengager de ses
responsabilités en transférant de
nombreuses compétences sans les moyens
correspondants aussi bien à l'échelon
national que local l'état persiste à
mener une politique fiscale injuste au
profit des plus riches tandis que les
départements font face à une hausse
soutenue des dépenses sociales lié
certes aux effets de la crise mais aussi
à l'application du revenu de solidarité
active entre autres dont l'état doit
assumer pourtant la compensation totale
je vous renvoie cela notre proposition
de loi sur ce sujet mais également à
divers transferts de compétences en
second lieu l'année 2011 sera celle de
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle pour les
collectivités 2010 ayant été une haine
et de transition durant laquelle l'état
versait une petite compensation aux
collectivités mais les effets de la
réforme se feront donc pleinement sentir
dès 2011 au moment des débats concernant
la suppression de cette taxe monsieur
estrosi s'était engagé à ce que cette
suppression ne déséquilibre pas les
investissements et les politiques
d'aménagement des collectivités des
territoires
or comme nous l'avions prédit les
investissements des collectivités
locales ont diminué de 2,1 pour cent en
2010 et ce n'est qu'un début
le gouvernement voit en cette baisse une
marque de prudence des collectivités
dans la gestion de leur budget il se dit
certainement tient lorsque nous leur
serrer un peu la ceinture ils dépensent
mieux eh bien non les collectivités ne
dépense pas mieux elles sont simplement
contrainte d'interrompre de reporter des
chantiers de construction
et c'est bien évidemment les usagers du
service public qui on souffre en premier
lieu avec notamment des routes
défectueuses et moins de logements mais
c'est aussi les entreprises et notamment
du bâtiment qui se voit contrainte de
baisser leurs effectifs au final c'est
donc l'emploi qui ont pâti alors que
vous vous targuez de vouloir le
préserver voire même de l'augmenter de
la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle qui selon vous devait
inciter les entreprises embauchent t
aujourd'hui donc la diminution des
investissements contraint les
entreprises à licencier
encore une fois vous jouez de
l'apparence et vous donner d'une main ce
que vous reprenez de l'autre mais nous
n'en sommes pas dupes et les citoyens
non plus enfin l'occasion de l'ouverture
du premier congrès des maires monsieur
sarkozy s'est félicité d'une réforme
territoriale équilibrée
il n'a apparemment pas écouté les
inquiétudes des mères et des différents
élus continuant sa politique de
dénigrement de l'échelon local il montre
du doigt nos collectivités en leur
imputant ou et en leur faisant subir les
conséquences du déficit budgétaire
national à propos de politique de
dénigrement j'aimerais pourtant attiré
l'attention sur un projet sur lequel le
gouvernement réfléchit actuellement et
auxquelles monsieur sauget a évoqué il
s'agit de la mise en place
récente d'une modulation de dotations de
l'état aux collectivités en fonction de
critères de bonne gestion
certains d'entre nous s'interroge
quelles sont ces critères de bonne
gestion qui pourrait être met en place
mais je m'interroge en premier lieu sur
les objectifs de ce projet il m'apparaît
comme un projet pernicieux visons encore
une fois stigmatisé les élus pour une
grande partie bénévoles présumant de
leur mauvaise gestion
alors même qu'ils tendent être les
contre-pouvoirs et les amortisseurs
sociaux de votre politique antisociale
et sélective le gouvernement devrait
pourtant comprendre mais je pense qu'il
s'agit surtout de l'ignorer que si
effectivement nos villes ce dans une
situation financière tendue
ce n'est pas à cause d'une gestion et
responsable mais bien à cause de sa
politique de dotation restrictives dont
le présent projet de loi de finances est
l'illustration
vous l'avez donc compris nous ne pouvons
voter ces crédits
j'ai formé mais si ma chère collègue la
parole est maintenant à notre collègue
le président christian poncelet pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
salle étudiants
mais la parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans le
cadre de la discussion du projet de loi
de finances pour 2011 je souhaite
appeler l'attention du gouvernement sur
la situation des finances des
collectivités territoriales elle lui
demander de bien vouloir indiquer au
sénat dans quelles conditions ces
collectivités appelés à participer à
l'effort de redressement du solde des
finances publiques d'autres pays
pourront assumer l'an prochain
l'intégralité de leur mission elles
besoin de rappeler que ces collectivités
constitue un facteur important de
l'activité économique
elle assure en effet près de 74 % de
l'investissement public en france
elles ont ainsi largement contribué à
sortir notre pays de la récente crise
économique
nombreux sont par exemple les communes
de mon département les vosges qui ont
tenu à jouer pleinement leur rôle dans
la bataille contre la crise comme le
conseil général
elles l'ont fait en investissement
faut-il également précisé que ces
collectivités interviennent devenu de
manière majeure dans le domaine de
l'action sociale
pour s'en convaincre qu'il n'est que de
constater la forte demande sociale
procédant dans les relations du marché
du travail
demande à laquelle elles sont appelées à
satisfaire une grande partie du
financement
commentant fonction de leurs ressources
propres et des moyens qui leur sont
consentis dans le cadre du budget 2011
pourront-elles remplir leur mission
auprès de la population et conserver
leurs bénéfices niveau de partenariat
considérons dans un premier temps la
situation financière de ces
collectivités notamment celles des
départements
certains connaissent une situation
précaire voire sont à la veille de la
faillite
au point que lors du récent congrès de
l'assemblée des départements de france
les 102 présidents de conseils généraux
ont appelé à l'unanimité le gouvernement
à la recherche de remèdes durables sans
exclure le retour à une procédure
d'urgence pour sa part monsieur premier
nice a constaté publiquement que
certains départements connaissait de
grandes décisions
tu es financière cette dégradation
financière s'explique d'abord par la
perte insidieuse de la liberté fiscale
des collectivités
dès 2011 les départements ne pourront
fixer le taux est déterminé le produit
que d'un seul impôt la taxe sur le
foncier bâti
ce qui explique que la recette attendue
du point d'impôt selon terre a nettement
régressé à titre d'exemple dans le
département des vosges la valeur ce
point d'impôt est passé à 600 mille
euros en 2011 pour le seul impôt dont le
taux peut être fixés à savoir la taxe
sur le foncier bâti au lieu de 7
millions d'euros précédemment au titre
de l'ensemble constitué alors par la
taxe professionnelle la taxe
d'habitation le foncier bâti et le
foncier non bâti
l'écart à l'évidence est important cette
dégradation financière s'explique
également par les pertes liées à des
compensations de l'état très
partiellement effectué pour les
transferts de compétences cette
dégradation financière s'explique aussi
par le dynamisme des locations
universelles de solidarité versées par
les départements pour le compte de
l'état alors que les rentrées fiscales
connaissent une progression très très
modéré c'est là souligné par tous
l'effet de ciseau entre des recettes peu
dynamique et des dépenses
essentiellement sociales en forte
croissance ce qui pose à partir de ce
constat le problème du financement des
allocations de solidarité pour y
apporter une solution durable ne
conviendrait-il pas d'assurer ce
financement à partir d'un prélèvement
par exemple sur le produit la cg ce ne
serait pas illogique
cette idée a été présenté d'ailleurs
avignon
cette présentation de la situation des
finances locales fournit l'occasion de
mettre l'accent sur l'importance des
créances que les collectivités
territoriales ont parc vers celle
acquise sur l'étang à la suite de
transferts de compétences non
accompagnés des crédits globaux
correspondant cette affaire est certes
ancien le principe de compensation
financière lui transfère des compétences
a été prévu dès les premières lois de
décentralisation de 1982 1983 puis
érigées en principes constitutionnels en
mars 2003 et conformément à la loi du 13
août
la compensation financière sopo s'opère
par le fractionnement d'impôts nationaux
cependant de la mise en oeuvre la
décentralisation des écarts ont été
relevés entre les crédits prévus
est ce effectivement versé dans location
personnalités d'autonomie appli
couramment la porte en fournit un
exemple probant en fin de compte c'est
une créance importante de l'état sur les
départements le département ainsi acculé
à la suite des différents transferts de
compétences le montant pour mon
département des vosges a atteint 137
millions d'euros sur une période de six
ans et pour l'année 2011
il serait de l'ordre de 50 millions
d'euros soit l'équivalent d'un demi
budget annuel d'investissement pour ce
département investissements
indispensables au soutien d'activités
gratuites du département il est à noter
dans ce domaine aucun qu'aucun
gouvernement qu'il soit de gauche ou de
droite
la respecter la loi de 1982 et que
l'accroissement ces dettes de l'étang
c'est une situation financière
insupportable pour les départements
aussi sommes-nous très attentif à la
réponse que monsieur le ministre vous
voudrez bien apporter à la question
suivante quand et selon quelle procédure
le gouvernement entend il apporter une
solution ou lens ou lancinant problème
des compensations de transfert des
compétences et assurer aux collectivités
intéressées le juste retour des crédits
correspondants peut-être qu'on a mise en
place de la péréquation horizontale à
partir de la croissance escomptée
la cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises ou de droits de mutation à
titre onéreux permettra-t-elle
d'alimenter deux fonds dédiés à la
protection sociale
j'ai cependant pu observer au congrès de
l'union des 20 et 21 octobre dernier
qu'il n'y avait aucun département qui se
déclare et riche l'opération va donc
être particulièrement difficile à
appliquer comme dès lors les
départements pour comment dès lors les
départements pourront établir leur
budget pour 2011 alors qu'elles sont en
quelque sorte actes et la diminution des
recettes
l'augmentation des dépenses ces
publications qui paraît impossible à
résoudre et je crains en l'état une
faille improvisé d'ailleurs constatant
la détérioration résultant de la
réduction relative des recettes face à
l'augmentation forte des dépenses de
transfert
compétences subi la cour des comptes a
cru déceler chez les responsables des
collectivités territoriales ce qu'elle
nomme et je cite le ressenti d'une perte
d'autonomie
que faut-il en penser après examen des
principales dispositions budgétaires
pour 2009 aussi pour lever ces craintes
et permet aux collectivités d'avoir une
telle démarche budgétaire plus assurée
voudrait bien monsieur le ministre à
partir au sénat les précisions tu m'a
paru utile de demander et les réponses
aux questions qu'il m'a semblé opportun
de poser aujourd'hui au moment où il
fait l'activité préparent leur budget je
vous remercie l avance de vos précisions
merci monsieur le président merci
bien nous allons appeler maintenant
monsieur claude biver mon cher collègue
pour le groupe de l'union centriste et
pour quatre minutes
vous avez la parole et vous seuls merci
tandis qu'augmentait reviendra après la
séance n'avait la parole ce pays dans ce
ministre chers collègues je ne nous
étonnerait pas si derrière le président
poncelet mon discours paraît d'être plus
vide mais certainement dans le même
esprit puisque nous partageons la fine
région ces difficultés de cette région
est les problèmes que posent
effectivement les chiffres dont question
poncelet vient de se faire l'écho
nous savons que la france se trouve dans
une situation financière et budgétaire
particulièrement contraintes et inégale
maintenant que le devais gouvernement
ait cru devoir procéder au gel des
dotations versées par l'état aux
collectivités territoriales pour 2011
j'observe néanmoins que ce gel conduit
en réalité à une baisse d'un an et demi
pour cent du montant de ces crédits
c'est à dire à due concurrence du taux
d'inflation retenu en 2011 ceci va
comprennent des communes les
intercommunalités les départements ou
les régions à réduire quelque peu leur
train de vie de l'année prochaine cela
sera sans doute plus facile pour celles
et ceux qui sont relativement aisées
mais à n'en pas douter bien plus
difficile pour les communes rurales qui
n'ont un déjà pas beaucoup de ressources
et les départements ruraux également
qu'ils n'ont pas d'attentes davantage
je pense bien entendu aux communes de
mon département que je représente ici le
seul motif de satisfaction que je
retiens dans les propositions formulées
par le gouvernement
c'est le fait que les dotations de
solidarité vont malgré tout progressé de
6%
mais on sait que si bon sens sur une
somme donnée et 6% sur une somme moitié
moins vouloir diviser par trois ou
quatre
eh bien nous ne sommes pas tout à fait
dans le même registre du calcul mais
aller à l'énoncé de ces chiffres on voit
bien qu'il y ait un réel problème
oui 136 communes urbaines vont se
partager un milliard trois cents
millions
d'euros de déçus en 2011 soit un million
cinq cent trente et un mille si je le
dis par ville c'est comme ça qu'on peut
l'exprimer dans le même temps 34 1866
commune plus modestes vont se partager
850 millions on est pas on ne joue pas
dans la même cour en six ans cela vient
d'être dit les crédits ont certes doublé
mais de 800 secte de 401 millions nous
passons à 850 millions pour la dsr et de
600 du passons à un milliard trois cents
millions en déçu il y a donc là toujours
ses différences et qui s'inclut pourquoi
une telle différence donc de traitement
entre communes urbaines et rurales
je demande solennellement au
gouvernement de mettre fin cette
disparité qu'il n'y a absolument pas
justifiée nous parlons régulièrement à
la tribune et ailleurs de péréquation de
péréquation nous appelons de nos voeux
cette péréquation mais décidément et
elle a du mal à venir et on sait qu'à
l'origine les calculs de dotations de
l'état ont été ont reposé sur à l'époque
la taxe locale qui était très différente
évidemment entre les villes et villages
en d'autres termes les villes qui
étaient riches dans les années 60 et 70
personnes aujourd'hui encore plus de 10
gev que les autres c'est disparité de
situations sont tout simplement
insupportable et peuvent être chiffrés
la garantie de production de propre
gestion minimale qui avait été instauré
à 81,13 a cristallisé les disparités
financières dont je viens de vous parler
le comprennent garantie en 2004 a
maintenu ses différences je me suis fait
communiquer les chiffres de dgf de la
ville de paris par exemple où nous
retrouvons un milliard deux cent
quarante deux millions ce qui représente
600 euros par habitant alors que nos
communes rurales sont à moins de 100
euros
dans un département n'est à moins de 100
euros dans notre département et je
trouve ça tout à fait anormal bien sûr
paris n'est pas la seule ville dans ce
cas et c'est à suivre
une ville la plus la ville la plus
emblématique
au total les crédits affectés aux
compléments de crédit de la dgf s'élève
à 5 milliards mais repose toujours sur
des situations acquises de longue date
mais ce billet si vous cherchez des
moyens budgétaires pour aller dans l'ain
dans le phénomène de péréquation vous
avez là une possibilité qui n'est pas
négligeable je sais que vous avez déjà
puiser un peu puisque vous allez jusqu'à
5% de ce complément de garantie que qui
sera récupérée est répartie mais je vois
que nous pouvions aller plus loin encore
il y a urgence en matière de péréquation
et je crois que nous ne pouvons qu'y
insisté il n'est pas normal en effet de
laisser ce hub si subsistent et de
telles injustices à conclure monsieur
biver et et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'insiste sur ce phénomène
il est il est au total le mode de calcul
de la dgf avantage aujourd'hui encore
les plus riches et c'est de là mon
insistance comme celle de beaucoup de
nos collègues je n'en doute pas on a
vraiment l'impression qu'il existe des
communes de première zone et des
communes de seconde zone crois qu'il est
temps que nous puissions véritablement
mettre en application la politique que
nous souhaitons vivement dans chacune de
nos réunions de commissions où il a
semblé et je compte sur mon monsieur le
ministre pour mettre un terme tout cela
si c'est possible en tout cas aller dans
le bon sens pour permettre aux communes
locales les tuent les plus faibles de
mieux comprendre de mieux saisir leur
eau pure propres opportunités et de
l'est de les envoyer de les faire
avancer vers une compréhension beaucoup
plus naturelle qui partira de ces
chiffres nouveaux médecins merci mon
cher collègue
la parole est maintenant à monsieur jean
pierre sueur pour le groupe socialiste
pour 10 minutes maximum la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je voulais d'abord
vous présenter mes voeux de réussite
dans votre mission
d'autant plus que cette mission est
difficile et je voulais aussi vous
souhaiter beaucoup de courage
tant le mécontentement des élus locaux
de notre république eux est profond et
j'ai écouté comme mes collègues avec
beaucoup d'intérêt les orateurs
précédents
et c'est vrai que ils ont parlé avec
tout leur coeur et beaucoup de
conviction et c'est vrai que dans la
droite ligne dans le droit fil de leurs
paroles
on s'attendrait presque à ce qu'ils
votent contre ce texte
mais je accorde volontiers à monsieur le
président poncelet qu'il arrive dans
l'existence politique que l'on soit
discipliné cela arrive de part et
d'autre mais enfin quand le vote n'est
acquis qu'au prix de la discipline il y
a quand même un déficit
chacun le sait alors monsieur le
ministre donc je vais commencer par
quelque chose de positif
après avoir dit tout cela j'ai bien noté
que la ds eu la dsi augmenté de 77
millions d'euros et que la dde augmenté
de 50 millions d'euros
on aurait pu souhaiter de plus grande
augmentation mais enfin ces
augmentations ne seront pas inutiles
dans les zones urbaines et dans les
quartiers en difficulté
je voulais le noter ceci étant dit je ne
vais pas naturellement sans traitement
propose sur les 2 milliard 5 encore que
2 milliards 5 ce n'est pas rien de ce
budget mais vous savez bien que ce
budget ne constitue qu'une petite partie
des relations financières entre l'état
et les collectivités locales qui sait
lève à 99 milliards d'euros donc je vais
d'abord dire redire puisque cela a été
dit par monsieur poncelet combien il est
inacceptable pour nous et c'était dû
aussi par madame bâton il est
inacceptable pour nous que l'on puisse
dire
imaginez dans la république que les
dotations de l'état à l'avenir serait
fonction je cite de la bonne gestion des
collectivités qui peut juger de la bonne
sexuelle gestion des collectivités dans
une république qui a choisi la
décentralisation est dans une république
tout court sinon les citoyens et les
citoyennes et je considère et nous
considérons que cette parole est
véritablement une parole de trop
offensante pour les élus locaux dans la
république ce sont les électeurs qui
jugent et nous n'accepterions pas et je
ne sais pas qui ici accepterait qu'il y
eut un comité qui jugeraient de la bonne
ou mauvaise gestion des diverses
collectivités locales monsieur jean
pierre raffarin a beaucoup insisté pour
que l'on inscrive dans la constitution
l'autonomie fiscale des collectivités
locales s'est inscrit dans la
constitution
mais depuis qu'on inscrit cela dans la
l'autonomie fiscale régresse je parlais
avec monsieur le vern qui est président
de région et qui sait très bien comme
tous ses collègues présidents de région
que les régions n'ont plus aucune
autonomie puisque leur budget dépend de
manière pratiquement exclusive des
dotations de l'état donc inscrire cela
dans la constitution c'est bien mais
réduire chaque jour
l'autonomie fiscale des collectivités ce
n'est pas bien
et à l'intérieur des 99 milliards dont
je parlais tout à l'heure vous savez mes
chers collègues qui lie à 21 milliards
qui correspondent soit des dégrèvements
soit des compensations d'exonérations
fiscales décidées par l'état ce qui veut
dire que le contribuable national est
devenu le principal contribuable local
et qu'il y à là quelque chose qui me
semble-t-il est profondément malsain
mais ce même si c'est malsain on
constate que cela progresse davantage et
cela progresse encore nous le savons
tous
avec la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle
donc notre voeu c'est bien sûr que l'on
aille vers une plus grande autonomie
fiscale à un moment où l'on va vers
toujours moins d'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités
je voulais avant d'aborder la question
de la péréquation mais tout est lié
dire un mot sur la complexité
monsieur le ministre nous sommes dans un
océan de complexité je sais qu'il y a de
très brillant personnel responsable la
dgcl je le rends aux vaches chaque année
parce que je connais leur grande
connaissance du sujet mais je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il y ait plus de 10 personnes
dans ce pays qui soit capable d'exposer
et de comprendre la totalité du système
des dotations financières de l'état aux
collectivités locales
c'est devenu tellement incompréhensible
que cela porte un problème pour la
démocratie car lorsque plus personne ne
comprend rien eh bien il est très
difficile pour les élus et les citoyens
de peser dans le débat
tout le monde le sait et il faudra
simplifier les choses et mes chers
collègues je veux finir en parlant de la
péréquation la différence de richesse
entre les régions va de 1 à 2 entre les
départements de 1 à 4 entre les communes
de 1 à 1000 il y a beaucoup d'inégalités
dans nos systèmes financiers relatifs
aux collectivités locales
il n'ya pas d'adéquation entre les
charges des collectivités et leurs
ressources
c'est pourquoi la péréquation devrait
être beaucoup plus forte
alors on ne cesse de parler de la
péréquation mais moi je suis prêt à
défendre que dans l'ensemble appelé dgf
la péréquation réel je dis bien réelle
ne dépasse pas 10% alors je sais on me
dira mais il y a dix dotation de
péréquation en effet il y à la ddr il y
à la dge
il y a là des dix premiers points
deuxièmement il y à l'intérieur de la
dgf
cette dotation de péréquation monsieur
le ministre vous les connaissez tout il
ya la dotation nationale de
fonctionnement minimale qui a une
fonction perry catrice légère la
dotation de péréquation des régions la
dotation d'intercommunalité
il y à la dotation de péréquation
urbaine il y à la dsi il y à la dsr et
ya bien sûr la 7e qui s'appelle dotation
de péréquation et même dotation
nationale de péréquation pour que chacun
comprenne bien
mais très franchement quand on regarde
de près ce dispositif on voit que
derrière les mots il n'ya pas toujours
autant de péréquation qu'on veut bien le
dire d'une part parce que dans ce
système les dotations dit de péréquation
comme la ds suez la dsr sont souvent le
résultat des calculs relatifs à la
dotation forfaitaire autrement dit ceux
qui restent
deuxièmement parce qu'on a une dotation
d'intercommunalité qui a je le sais une
dimension perret catrice mais qui pour
l'essentiel n'est pas père et quoi
triste parce qu'il ne suffit pas d'être
une institution intercommunal pour être
riche ou pour être pauvre
cela n'a pas une minute trottoirs de
rapport
monsieur le président et enfin parce que
l'on a parfois des dotations je pense à
la dsr mes chers collègues
vous savez que 34 1369 comme une touche
la dsr très bien mais la dimension perry
quadris de la dsr elle est en réalité
très faibles alors il y a beaucoup
d'effets pervers dans ce système et le
fond de la faire c'est qu'on n'ose pas
mettre en oeuvre une vraie péréquation
moi je souhaiterais qu'il y ait moins de
dotations de l'état et moins de
transfert de fiscalité dans ces
dotations et plus de péréquation à
l'intérieur de ces dotations alors
monsieur le président je vais conclure
en disant qu'il a été question dans
notre pays il ya quelques temps de la
rupture
eh bien nous pourrions souhaité une
rupture plus d'investissements ça veut
dire donner aux collectivités locales
les moyens d'investir quitte à faire des
choix
c'est absolument nécessaire quand on
sait le poids qui est le leur dans
l'investissement plus de solidarité
alors qu avec si peu de péréquation il
n'y a pas la solidarité nécessaire et
enfin plus de décentralisation
c'est à dire de libertés locales parce
que nous avons le sentiment qu'un
certain nombre de dispositions récentes
et je pense à la réforme territoriale
vont plutôt dans le sens de la
recentralisation pour la solidarité pour
la décentralisation pour les libertés
locales et pour l'investissement
il faut une autre politique merci mon
cher collègue parfait la parole est
maintenant à peu près collègue jean
michel baylet pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique social et
européen n'avait la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le président monsieur
mille mes chers collègues après
l'adoption du désastreux je vois bien le
dire projet de loi de réforme des
collectivités territoriales dans l'est
soit dit en passant dans les conditions
que l'on sait
ici je dis plus fortement dans cette
enceinte avec les pressions que l'on
sait l'économie des ressources que cette
loi de finances affecte aux
collectivités démontre s'il fallait
encore le peu de considération que le
gouvernement réserve aux collectivités
et aussi aux élus qui gèrent avec il
faut les saluer volonté sur hilarité
dévouement la loi de finances pour 2010
avait donné naissance à la contribution
économique territoriale destiné à
remplacer la taxe professionnelle on
nous avait promis que la suppression atp
ne porterait en aucun cas atteinte à la
capacité financière des collectivités et
même que l'état monsieur le ministre
pourquoi garonne en cas de défaillance
budgétaire nous avons pris ça a été dit
et c'est pas la réalité
nous avons vu surtout une régression
majeure de l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités les régions ça a été dit
parce qu'ils m'ont précisé cette tribune
est celle du ont précédé de ce côté
comme de ce côté donc de droite comme de
gauche les régions totalement perdu leur
pouvoir de modulation fiscales tandis
que les départements ont vu le leur
divisé par trois passant de 36 à 12 %
parallèlement le gel des dotations de
l'état va lourdement peser sur les
perspectives d'investissement des
collectivités en particulier pour celles
qui ne bénéficieront pas du fonds
national de garantie individuelle ou de
la dotation de compensation de la
réforme de la tp
enfin cette réforme inique vendre un
transfert massif de l'impôt sur les
ménages dont la contribution sur lokad
va passer de 4 10% à 72 % environ
voilà un message mes chers collègues qui
réjouira certainement ses pairs en ces
périodes de noël
nous combattrons les plus modestes ceux
là même qui se débattent au quotidien
dans les situations les plus dramatiques
liées à la crise économique
en tout cas le gel de l'ensemble des
dotations de trois ans est une nouvelle
attaque frontale contre les libertés
locales et ce n'est
que le dernier avatar d'une politique
visant orchestrée depuis maintenant huit
ans le recul de cette autonomie
financière pourtant inscrits s'étaient
rappelé aussi la réforme apparaît à
l'article 72 de la constitution
dans quel but si ce n'est le transfert
aux collectivités une partie de plus en
plus important de bien plus massive du
lourd très lourd trop lourd déficit de
l'état et faire supporter aux élus
locaux la responsabilité d'une incurie
budgétaire qui aime comme monsieur le
ministre votre majorité
concrètement 14000 communaux interco
romu en 2010 une baisse en euros
courants de leur dotation alors que
l'enveloppé nommé normes et province
encore de 0,6 l'année prochaine ce sont
vingt-cinq mille communes
intercommunalités qui suivit rôle cet
étranglement financier qu'il aura aura
désormais toute marge de manoeuvre
à cela s'ajoute l'étouffement des
départements et des régions 27
départements mes chers collègues sont en
2010 voir la cessation de paiement
quarante à cinquante le seront
certainement l'an prochain du seul fait
de leur incapacité à faire face à
l'effet ciseau de charges toujours plus
lourdes mais de ressources de plus en
plus rares monsieur le ministre il ne
faut pas même si vous arrivez resté
sourd à la colère de ces milliers d'élus
locaux de tous bords qui arrive de moins
en moins à établir un budget permettant
de satisfaire les besoins de leurs
administrés vous le savez bien
en raison de la ponction que leur impose
l'état il est absurde de faire croire de
vouloir croire de vouloir se persuader
que c'est en a - collectivités qu'elles
dépasseront - alors même que les besoins
locaux et particulièrement concernant
les services publics n'ont jamais été
aussi urgent les collectivités
territoriales ont toujours réussi
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en tout cas à
satisfaire à leurs obligations légales
de voter des budgets non déficitaire de
plus parce que eux doivent voter des
budgets en équilibre comme trame à
l'état de plus la part du déficit des
administrations publiques locales dans
les piscines publiques a diminué cette
année représente à peine 10 %
comment dans ces conditions l'état qui
n'a pas voté un budget en équilibre
1981 peut-il vouloir faire la leçon aux
élus locaux
comment une majorité qui a porté notre
dette publique de 900 milliards à 1700
milliards d'euros entre 2002 et 2011 aux
hôtels donner des leçons de gestion
il aimait s'y recoller tout simplement
inconcevable que ce soit les mêmes qui
prétendent même moduler les dotations de
l'état en fonction de critères de bonne
gestion de critères qu'ils définissent
eux-mêmes au mépris du principe de libre
administration alors monsieur le
ministre il est faux de dire que les
collectivités sont dans l'impasse
parce qu'elles ont trop dépensé et même
prétendons parfois trop embauché
je vous rappellerai que les transferts
de compétences massivement opéré depuis
2004 n'ont pas été accompagnés des
compensation intégrale que la loisne
dans un état les conseils généraux n'ont
ainsi reçu que huit milliards d'euros
sur les 12 milliards que l'état réduit
leur verser aux petits des prestations
sociales dont il a la charge et nous
attendons d'ailleurs encore d'où notre
proposition de loi déposée par le groupe
rds se disant a obligé l'état à
intégralement compenser les charges dues
au titre des allocations individuelles
de solidarité versée par département
c'est aussi les collectivités qui
financent 96 % des budgets de 10 dont
56% pour les conseils généraux et qui
paye les décisions qui sont prises par
l'état et le gouvernement
par exemple sur coup de la mise en
oeuvre du dispositif intéresse je vous
appellerai je vous rappellerai aussi que
les embauches effectuées par les
collectivités correspondant à des
transferts de personnels ou à des
budgets des besoins réels pour
satisfaire les besoins des administrés
je vous rappellerai enfin que le sens de
ce transfert s'est opéré de manière
coercitive de la part de l'état sans
concertation aucune alors que la
recherche de consensus aurait dû être
aux socialistes dans mon département le
préfet interrogé voulez vous que les
routes nationales sont transférés chez
monsieur le préfet je vais réunir le
conseil qu'on me demandait si la réponse
est oui je commun que si oui mais si la
réponse est non il m'a dit c'est réponse
est oui si oui si la réponse est non si
oui est ce ici lui fait alors que nous
étions posés par 29 voix sur 30 alors
d'hommes se munissant conduisons
l'avenir est sombre pour nos
collectivités et particulièrement bien
sûr les zones rurales en restreignant
les possibilités de cofinancement
subventions votre projet de réforme des
collectivités va contraindre les élus à
revoir leurs investissements et
abandonnés ou même à privatiser
si safran peu de pluie à certains les
services publics cette perspective que
vous offrir en étranglant les finances
locales
c'est donc celle de la disparition des
solidarités locales
cette perspective les radicaux de gauche
ainsi d'ailleurs que la majorité des
membres du rds la refuse avec
détermination
en conséquence nous ne voterons pas les
crédits de la mission relations avec les
collectivités territoriales si mon cher
collègue parole est maintenant entre
collègues
rémy pointereau pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
mais la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
ce projet de budget s'inscrit dans un
contexte très contraint et l'étape
maintient pourtant pour 2011 ces
dotations et ses concours aux
collectivités territoriales après la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle celle
des collectivités territoriales et dans
le prolongement du congrès des maires
tenue la semaine dernière je souhaitais
faire quelques observations
relayant les questionnements et les
inquiétudes des élus au delà du cadre de
cette mission du budget qui ne porte que
sur une petite partie de l'effort
financier de l'état en faveur des
collectivités territoriales j'évoquerai
donc plus largement que cette mission
les problèmes que les élus se posent sur
les finances locales
ma première observation sur la fusion de
la dotation globale d'équipement et la
dotation de développement rural créant
une nouvelle dotation d'équipement des
territoires ruraux
dans le prolongement du siat et sur
l'initiative conjointe des ministres de
l'intérieur et de la ruralité
cette fusion associé à la simplification
des critères de répartition de la
dotation et à l'uniformisation des
procédures d'attribution vise à mieux
répondre aux besoins d'équipement
exprimer c'est un signe positif en
direction des communes rurales
permettez-moi toutefois d'exprimer la
crainte à ce stade que cette fusion
pénalise au final les commune ou
l'intercommunalité la ddr était plutôt
ces derniers temps réservé aux
intercommunalités et des précisions
quant aux critères d'éligibilité à cette
dotation est haut et au périmètre exact
des actions qu'elle pourra concerner
serait sans doute utile car certains
départements ont stoppé carrément leur
aide aux communes et il conviendra donc
que cette nouvelle dotation soient
répartis de façon équitable entre
communes et intercommunalités
j'évoquerai en second lieu la
péréquation verticale et en particulier
la dgf celle des dotations qui à mon
sens
génère le plus d'inégalités entre
collectivités pour exprimer des
inquiétudes des maires ruraux
sachant que la dotation forfaitaire de
base des communes varie de 64 euros à
128 euros par habitant en fonction de la
taille de la commune
nous devons réduire à terme cette
distorsion qui pénalise la ruralité
je formulerai par ailleurs une
observation sur la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle qui sera surtout discuté
au au moment de l'examen des articles
non rattachés à l'article 59
l'année 2011 constitue un tournant pour
les finances locales maire d'une commune
rurale et président de l'association des
maires de mon département
j'attire en particulier l'attention sur
la part de l'ifer attribuée aux communes
pour la production éolienne et
poursuivant ainsi le débat qui a eu lieu
l'an passé le relèvement à 5 euros
proposé dans le projet de loi de
finances contre 2.9 113 euros l'an passé
est une petite avancée mais ce
relèvement est encore nettement
insuffisant puisqu'il faudrait au
minimum 8 euros par kilowatt pour
compenser les pertes de recettes calculé
de l'ancienne tp
les simulations effectuées le montre
bien et de nombreux maires s'interroge à
la proche de la préparation de leur
budget pour 2011 sur la réalité de leurs
ressources avant la réforme de la tp
les recettes fiscales par éolienne
étaient en moyenne en moyenne de trente
mille euros à répartir entre communes
communautés de communes et départements
depuis les recettes ont chuté à moins de
10000 euros par éolienne à répartir
entre les trois collectivités des
communes qui ont anticipé
l'implantation d'éoliennes sur leur
territoire se retrouvent ainsi
aujourd'hui pénalisée par rapport aux
prévisions
j'ai donc déposé plusieurs amendements
visant d'une part à a relevé le montant
de l'ifer jusqu'à 8 euros par kilowatt
que je présenterai à l'article 59 et
j'ai également déposé plusieurs
amendements visant à modifier
la répartition de cet hiver au profit
des communes soit 50 % 40 % pour les
communautés de communes et 10% pour les
départements en effet les départements
ne peuvent prétendre à une part aussi
élevée que celle prévue initialement à
savoir 30 % dans la mesure où toutes les
démarches sont réalisées par le bloc
communal et que les éventuelles
nuisances sont plus local que
départemental
s'agissant des départements à la suite
du rapport jamet l'annoncent fait il y a
quelques mois par le gouvernement d'une
aide aux départements en situation
d'urgence financière me paraît très
positive
le contrat de stabilité proposé aux
termes duquel les départements pourront
recevoir une avance voir une dotation en
échange d'un programme de stabilisation
de leurs dépenses ne paraît de bon sens
et j'avais d'ailleurs écrit au premier
ministre pour inscrire le département du
cher qui est dans les dix départements
les plus en difficulté pour pouvoir
bénéficier de cette mission d'appui et
j'ai noté avec satisfaction que le
gouvernement traduirait cette démarche
dans la prochaine loi de finances
rectificative voilà monsieur le ministre
les interrogations que je souhaitais
vous soumettre en vous renouvelant mes
félicitations pour votre nomination est
toute ma confiance sachant que vous
connaissez parfaitement les
collectivités pour soutenir ces
collectivités dans leur ensemble pour
rétablir les équilibres qui sont
fragiles sur cette certaine partie de
notre territoire en confortant la
ruralité et pour corriger des inégalités
et des pertes de recettes dues à des
bases de calcul trop faible prévus dans
la loi de finances 2010 tout cela
permettra j'en suis sûr un aménagement
du territoire plus équilibré et plus
harmonieux je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant madame
jacqueline gourault pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
vous avez la parole monsieur collègue
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
beaucoup de choses ont été dites
simplement rappelé évidemment que par le
gel des dotations aux collectivités
locales pendant trois ans l'état appelle
au fond les collectivités locales à
participer à la lutte contre le déficit
bien sûr on ne peut pas être contre mais
comme cela a été rappelé tout à l'heure
à la hauteur je dirais de nos
responsabilités dans la mesure où les
collectivités locales ne représente que
10% de l'endettement global de la france
mais je voudrais dire aussi que ce gel
intervient à la suite de la réforme de
la taxe professionnelle est au fond je
voudrais relayer ici l'angoissent des
élus qui voient désormais que l'état à
deux leviers
non seulement le gel des dotations mais
d'un autre côté bien évidemment
puisqu'il y à eut ressenti ralisation
fiscale perte du pouvoir fiscal des
collectivités locales eh bien l'état à
de levier sur les recettes des
collectivités locales donc gel d'un côté
plus contrôle de la cotisation de sur la
valeur ajoutée il y a une grande
angoisse et les collectivités locales
craignent de ne plus pouvoir assumer je
dirais leur mission sur le territoire
car il faut bien mesurer
monsieur le ministre que naturellement
les français et on le sait malgré le
fait malgré les paroles rassurantes de
la ministre de l'économie
on sait que la situation n'est pas bonne
et les français savent aussi que les
temps vont être durs mais il faut
comprendre que si les collectivités
locales n'ont plus les moyens d'assumer
un certain nombre de politiques de
proximité
eh bien ça deviendra de plus en plus
insupportable pour nos concitoyens et ça
je voudrais bien leur faire sentir ici
au niveau national je crois qu'il faut
que le gouvernement comprenne cela avant
je dirais qu'il ne soit trop tard
le deuxième point que je voudrais
préciser c'est de regretter que le
gouvernement et obtenu le retrait par
une deuxième délibération à l'assemblée
nationale de plusieurs dispositions
favorables aux collectivités
territoriales nous espérons monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président du sénat
qui si dans cette assemblée
celle qui représente les collectivités
locales
et bien que le gouvernement le
gouvernement fera preuve d'un peu plus
d'habilité si je puis dire
et puis surtout que nos collègues ne se
ne se laisseront pas aller à voter des
deuxièmes délibérations qui annulerait
les décisions que nous aurions voté
auparavant
troisième point que je voudrais signaler
il s'agit d'une demande au gouvernement
de simulation des effets de la baisse de
la dotation de garantie car si ces
simulations sont globalement de 130
millions c'est-à-dire de 2,54 % c'est
évolutions sont différenciées selon le
niveau des communes et nous aimerions
avoir bien évidemment des évaluations
des simulations plus précises sur les
conséquences de la baisse de la dotation
de garantie
quatrièmement ça déjà été évoquée par
mon collègue du cher rémy pointereau il
y a une grande inquiétude sur la fusion
de la dge et de la ddr parce que vous
savez quand on dit on fusionne on a
toujours tort qu'à la sortie n'est ce
pas y en ait moins qu'à l'entrée et donc
nous espérons que toutes les communes
qui ont bénéficié en bénéficieront
toujours
et puis je voudrais rappeler le rôle
essentiel de la commission d'élus et
nous voudrions qu'elle soit conservée
pour
cette répartition comme elle l'était
pour la ddr auparavant je termine
monsieur le président juste parce que
plusieurs de mes collègues m'ont demandé
d'intervenir sur ce point même si c'est
un peu en marge notamment nathalie
goulet j'allais le dire cher nathalie
suite à la loi sur la réforme des
collectivités territoriales
il est prévu bien sûr dans chaque
département l'élection d'une commission
départementale de coopération
intercommunale
nous souhaiterions beaucoup que le
décret ou où je sais pas si c'est un
décret ou sortent le plus rapidement
possible qu'à nous aimerions que tout
cela soit fait rapidement et surtout
avant que ne s'engage la campagne des
élections cantonales qui pourrait
perturber un peu les élections à la cdc
je pense qu'il serait de bon aloi que
cela aille rapidement je vous remercie
collègues
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
georges patient apparenté au groupe
socialiste
ces charges vous avez la parole vous
chers collègues sur le président est ce
le ministre ces chers collègues
l'enveloppent de la mission relations
avec les collectivités territoriales
pour 2011 de 2 55 milliards d'euros de
crédits en autorisations d'engagement et
2,51 milliards d'euros en crédits de
paiement
ces crédits ne représente que 2,6 pour
cent du montant total des relations
financières entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales qui lui
s'élève à plus de 98 milliards d'euros
mais cette mission retrace les crédits
affectés aux collectivités locales au
titre de la dotation générale de
décentralisation des dotations
d'investissement et d'autres aides
spécifiques de rita aux collectivités
qui sont intégrés dans le périmètre des
dotations concernée par le gel en valeur
sur les trois prochaines années 2011 à
2014 conformément à la règle d'évolution
zéro valeur prescrite dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour 2011 2014
l'article 20 du projet de loi de
finances gel des dotations de
fonctionnement tels que les dotations
générale de décentralisation
l'article 21 du même texte gel des
dotations d'investissement tels que les
dotations globales d'équipement
cette formation des dotations aura des
effets négatifs sur les capacités
d'intervention des collectivités est
d'ores et déjà la note de conjoncture
publiée le mercredi 17 novembre par
dexia crédit local avance un recul de 2
1% des investissements publics locaux en
2010 et une chute qui se poursuivra en
2011 puisque le projet de loi de
finances pour 2011 et voit une
diminution de 3 1% du montant du fonds
de compensation pour la tva l'année
prochaine plus grave encore sera
l'impact de la réduction des concours
financiers de l'état sur les
départements régions d'outre-mer qui a
raison de compétences plus larges que
celles des collectivités métropolitaines
en décharge nécessairement plus élevé
les dépenses de fonctionnement par
habitant des collectivités territoriales
des dom sont en effet d'un niveau
largement supérieur à celle de la
moyenne des collectivités françaises
plus 82% pour les régions + 88 % pour le
département et +17 % pour les communes
outre l'effet des charges de personnel
ce déséquilibre résulte également du
poids des dépenses sociales dans les
budgets des collectivités territoriales
cela conduit nécessairement pour les
finances départementales notamment à une
situation particulièrement tendue en
raison de l'importance de ces dépenses
sociales la sous compensation penske en
valeur absolue plus lourd dans les
musées départementaux d'outre-mer que
dans ceux de métropole
de même les dogues présentent des
spécificités historiques qui justifie un
effort accru en matière
d'investissements infrastructures de
transport équipement scolaire logement
social en raison de ses besoins
importants
les dépenses d'investissement des
collectivités territoriales devrait être
logiquement supérieure à celle des
collectivités métropolitaines
ce qui n'est pas le cas elles sont plus
faibles que celles de métropole en
raison du poids des dépenses de
fonctionnement qui induit une moindre
capacité d'investissement et de
nombreuses insatisfactions locale en
l'état effectue pourtant à elle seule
plus de 70 % des investissements publics
qui sont de loin les moteurs de
l'activité économique des départements
d'outre-mer sans cesse nous alertons sur
cette situation qui réclamant une plus
grande adaptation des concours
financiers de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales des départements
d'outre-mer voir une dotation de
rattrapage les réponses qui nous sont
apportés repose exclusivement sur la
responsabilisation des élus
l'accentuation de la pression fiscale
directe et indirecte sur une population
dans le quart seulement est assujettie
au paiement de l'impôt sur le revenu
puisque les départements d'outre-mer
bénéficierait déjà d'importantes
dotations de l'état à raison de droit de
règles de droit commun qui leur serait
plus favorable si la hausse de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement des
collectivités territoriales des dom est
certes supérieure à celle des
collectivités métropolitaines
cela résulte de leur croissance
démographique plus forte
aussi il est normal que les dotations de
l'état la prennent en compte puisque une
part importante de la dgf est déterminé
par le nombre d'habitants
la mission sénatoriale qui s'étaient
rendus dans les dom en 2009 avait pris
la pleine mesure de la situation en
identifiant les réels problèmes dans son
rapport qui est largement diffusé elle
émet plus de quinze propositions visent
à l'amélioration de la situation
financière des collectivités locales
le gouvernement a paru entendre mais à
ce jour on n'a pas su jouer à nouveau je
comprends certaines de ses propositions
sous forme d'amendement qui l'espère
seront adoptées merci merci chers
collègues maintenant nous allons dans
notre collègue benoît huré pour le
groupe ump dernière intervenant dans
cette discussion générale
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues la mission charge
des politiques à l'égard des
collectivités territoriales dans le
cadre de l'élaboration du projet de loi
de finances 2011 m'amène à vous faire
part de quelques remarques
je constate avec satisfaction alors
qu'une crise économique et financière
sans précédent
accable le monde et la france que le
gouvernement démontre dans ce projet de
budget qu'il continue malgré tout à
soutenir fortement les collectivités
territoriales dont la part des recettes
provenant de l'état représentent plus de
60%
on note en particulier une augmentation
des crédits de la dotation de
développement rural la dotation de
solidarité urbaine qui témoigne d'une
attention plus grande à l'égard des
territoires fragiles ce budget
intervient aussi dans l'actualité de la
réforme territoriale à laquelle le sénat
a apporté une contribution déterminante
largement inspiré par son enracinement
dans les réalités territoriales
si le bloc communal et intercommunal se
trouve confortée dans son évolution
les perspectives de mieux travailler
ensemble proposé aux départements et
régions renforceront le rôle nécessaire
et complémentaire de ces deux
institutions tout en répondant à la
nécessité incontesté de simplifier et de
clarifier le mode d'élection des
représentants des territoires
la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle est compensée et les
modalités de la répartition de l'impôt
économique nouveaux qui lui succède
s'inscrivent dans une volonté positive
et qui devra être renforcée largement
l'avenir de plus grandes péréquation
entre territoires
mon inquiétude par contre est grande
pour les mois et même les semaines à
venir
en ce qui concerne certains conseils
généraux car ceux ci à la différence des
autres niveaux de collectivités ont
en plus des missions classiques qui
échoit à toutes les autres le devoir de
mettre en oeuvre les politiques de
solidarité dont la charge liées à la
dépendance est au rmi rsa rsa sont en
train d'exploser
le premier ministre en décembre dernier
a lui-même reconnu la gravité de la
situation
il a nommé un expert monsieur pierre
jamet dont les conclusions sont claires
même si les perspectives budgétaires des
conseils généraux à partir de 2012
retrouve des fondamentaux plus solides
grâce à la mise en oeuvre du financement
par la nation de la dépendance au titre
du cinquième risque
il n'en reste pas moins que pour
certains départements dont celui des
ardennes qui combine les effets d'une
démographie vieillissante et ceux d'une
situation économique difficile ne
pourrons pas attendre cette échéance de
l'équation budgétaire de 2011 étant
quasiment impossible à résoudre les 150
millions d'euros de dotation
exceptionnelle récemment dégagé par le
gouvernement en faveur de quelques
dizaines de départements n'apporte
qu'une partie de la réponse pour
certains conseils généraux qui se
comptent sur les doigts d'une main dont
celui des ardennes pour les raisons que
je viens d'indiquer pour cela les
conclusions de la mission d'appui
constitué à l'initiative du premier
ministre attestent de la nécessité de
verser en urgence une dotation de
secours particulière monsieur le
ministre je fais confiance à l'ancien
sénateur et président de conseil général
que vous êtes à ce titre parfaitement
informés de la réalité des situations
des uns et des autres pour relayer cet
appel pressant auprès de monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le ministre je
vous renouvelle mes félicitations et mes
encouragements pour la responsabilité
ministérielle qui vient de vous être
confiées
je vous informe ainsi que mes collègues
que je voterai les crédits de la mission
dont nous débattons cet après midi
merci monsieur jurés bien mais mes chers
collègues nous allons maintenant
entendre notre ex collègue et ami
philippe richert ministre auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur de l'outre-mer
des collectivités rial et de
l'immigration chargé des collectivités
territoriales c'est le président
messieurs la porter mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs si vous le
permettez chers collègues j'ai bien
compris que le dossier n'est pas aisé je
vais y revenir et je souhaite le faire
comme j'ai toujours souhaité le faire
quand je siégeais sur les travées du
sénat en toute transparence parce que je
crois qu'au delà des débats où nous
sommes dans des responsables des
diverses
ce qui compte c'est la façon d'avancer
ensemble pour le bien commun de la
nation
mesdames et messieurs l'examen des
crédits et des articles rattachés la
mission relations avec les collectivités
territoriales constitue l'un des trois
mouvements des débats qu'offre ce projet
de finances en matière de finances
locales
en effet la semaine dernière vous avez
adopté la première partie de la loi de
finances et tout son volet relatif aux
prélèvements sur recettes de l'état au
profit des collectivités territoriales
puis en fin de semaine ou en début de
semaine prochaine j'aurai le plaisir
vous retrouver pour examiner les
articles relatifs à la clause de
rendez-vous de la taxe professionnelle
l'importance de ces débats et des
articles associés résulte de deux
organisations majeures de ce projet de
loi de finances tout d'abord la mise en
oeuvre concrète de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle pour les collectivités
territoriales
plusieurs d'entre vous en ont parlé et
ensuite la mise en oeuvre du gel des
concours financiers et la poursuite de
l'effort de péréquation avant de
présenter les crédits de la mission
relations avec des collectivités
territoriales je voudrais si vous le
permettez présenter ses orientations en
quelques mots et j'ai bien conscience
des difficultés devant lesquelles nous
nous trouvons tous quel que soit le
niveau de collectivités où nous exerçons
nos responsabilités évoquons tout
d'abord la clause de rendez-vous de la
taxe professionnelle se posent les
finances concrétise comme le
gouvernement s'y était engagé la clause
de rendez vous qui était une attente
forte
des parlementaires des élus locaux cette
clause de rendez-vous permet d'établir
une première évaluation de la réforme
tout d'abord les collectivités
territoriales je veux le redire ici
n'ont pas été asphyxiées par la
suppression de la tp d'ailleurs la
compensation relais de la tp perçue
cette année est en augmentation sensible
+32 7% par rapport au produit de la taxe
professionnelle
bercy l'an dernier permettez moi de le
redire ce ne sont pas des chiffres
farfelus
c'est la réalité cela représente mes
chers collègues 1,1 milliards de
ressources supplémentaires pour les
collectivités locales
quoi qu'on dise certes la
territorialisation des nouvelles
ressources continuent de faire débat
à mon sens c'est légitime les outils de
péréquation qui doivent être
progressivement mis en oeuvre pour le
niveau régional et le niveau
départemental un mécanisme de
péréquation sur la croissance de la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée la cvae
et pour le niveau départemental le
mécanisme sur les droits de mutation à
titre onéreux dmto introduit l'an
dernier à l'initiative du député marc
laffineur enfin au niveau communal ce
projet de finance ouvre le débat sur
l'instauration dès 2012 d'un nouveau
dispositif de péréquation des ressources
communales et intercommunales
selon les modalités décrites l article
63 vous savez mes chers collègues
tout le monde parle de péréquation et
quand on y arrive chacun trouve toujours
les raisons le dire que la péréquation
c'est d'abord pour les autres avant de
nous concerne et nous mêmes c'est sait
des choses que nous avons tous connu
nous avons tous sièges et et travailler
savait pratiquement trente ans que j'y
suis ça fait trente ans que je l'entends
le gouvernant souhaite que nous
puissions ainsi disposer d'une feuille
de route pour les travaux que nous
aurons à conduire en 2011
en étroite concertation avec le comité
des finances locales serre ne sera
porteur nous aurons l'occasion de
débattre de ces différents mécanismes
dans les tout prochains jours
enfin compte tenu des évolutions des
ressources des collectivités
territoriales nous avons dû adapter les
instruments de mesure des écarts de
richesse aux nouvelles ressources
fiscales des collectivités territoriales
on le faisait jusqu'à présent avec les
quatre bases bien c'est évident
qu'aujourd'hui avec les changements qui
ont été introduits et bien il faut en
trouver de nouvelles cette mesure est
indispensable pour la répartition des
dotations de péréquation
si nous n'avons plus de base comment
faire pour répartir c'est l'objet de
l'article 81
6 du projet de loi de finances rattaché
à la mission relations collectivités
territoriales qui propose de conserver
en 2011 pour la part de potentiel
financier à six sur la seule taxe
professionnelle les données utilisées
pour le calcul du potentiel financier en
2010 c'est à dire en fait les données de
ce choix a été fait afin de ne pas
perturber trop gravement la répartition
des dotations de péréquation au moment
où se met en place les nouvelles
ressources fiscales des collectivités
territoriales
naturellement l'an prochain un nouveau
potentiel fiscal prendre en compte les
nouvelles ressources fiscales des
collectivités territoriales c'était le
premier point j'en viens au deuxième
abordons à présent la stabilisation en
valeur pour la période du budget
triennal 2011-2013 des concours
financiers de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales
cette décision mesdames et messieurs
chers collègues a été prise lors de la
deuxième conférence des déficits publics
elle s'inscrit dans le cadre des
conclusions du rapport carrez sténo et
vise à appliquer au concours financier
de l'état
la même règle d'évolution que celles que
l'état fixe à ses propres dépenses
l'effort de maîtrise des finances
publiques concernent en effet l'ensemble
des dépenses publiques
d'autant que le contribuable finale est
toujours le même mais j'ai bien noté mes
chers collègues que bien entendu au
niveau des collectivités notamment en ce
qui concerne les dettes
nous ne sommes pas au niveau des
collectivités au même niveau que l'état
bien entendu et personne n'aurait
imaginé ici prétendre le contraire pour
mémoire je souhaite rappeler que le gel
ne porte que sur une enveloppe de 52,4
milliards d'euros ça c'est déjà pas mal
mais l'effort financier global de l'état
reste nettement supérieure à 7 ans
l'homme mais j'ai entendu les chiffres
tout à l'heure 77 milliards d'euros en
comptant les concours financiers les
dégrèvements au législatif d'impôts
locaux en réalité 99 milliards d'euros
en y ajoutant la fiscalité transféré en
compensation des transferts de
compétences cela représente tout de même
le premier post de ce budget loin devant
par exemple le budget de l'éducation
nationale qui lui se situe à 61 7
milliards
je le rappelle 99 milliards de dotation
pour les collectivités toutefois ce gel
vous le savez est accompagné de
plusieurs engagements forts premièrement
la stabilisation des concours financiers
de l'état ne veut pas concerner toutes
les dotations en effet
conformément aux préconisations des
messieurs car elles étaient nos le fctva
n'est pas inclus dans le périmètre visé
par le gel des dotations aux
collectivités territoriales ne seront
donc pas pénalisé par la croissance des
investissements que celle ci pourrait
mener les amendes de police également
sortent du périmètre du gène
deuxième point les effets de la réforme
de la tp et notamment la création de la
nouvelle dotation de compensation de la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle ne
pèseront pas sur les autres concours
financiers de l'état troisièmement les
dotations de péréquation vous continuez
à faire progresser et j'ai bien entendu
plusieurs interventions monsieur le
président poncelet sur ce sujet cela
témoigne de notre souhait de renforcer
l'équité entre les territoires et j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure lors des
examens des amendements qui sont déposés
ainsi à l'article 80 que nous
examinerons tout à l'heure il précise
que la dotation de solidarité urbaine et
de cohésion sociale augmentera de 67 77
millions d'euros monsieur le sua lesueur
la dotation de solidarité rurale
augmentera elle de 50 millions d'euros
cela représente 6,2 pour cent
d'augmentation pour chacune de ces deux
dotations cette augmentation sur a
certes gagée par la baisse d'autres
composantes de l'envelope je les ai
notamment d'un certain certaine part de
dgf
je précise toutefois que s'agissant de
l'écrêtement dû complètement garanti
celui ci ne sera plus appliquée de
manière uniforme comme les années
précédentes mais en fonction du
potentiel fiscal des communes
c'est une vraie mesures de
redistribution particulièrement
protectrice des petites communes les
communes les plus fragiles j'ajoute
qu'un amendement adopté à l'assemblée
nationale a permis de dégager une
ressource de 149 millions qui soulagera
les contraintes au sein du financement
de la péréquation
enfin je voudrais rappeler l'engagement
très fort du président de la république
de réduire le poids des normes pesant
sur les collectivités territoriales à
moratoire sur les normes nouvelles est
d'ores et déjà en vigueur depuis le 6
juillet dernier et un travail sans gars
sur le stock de normes existantes en
lien avec les trois associations d'élus
nationale troisième et dernier point je
voudrais à présent présenté brièvement
les crédits la mission relations entre
collectivités territoriales il porte sur
un montant modeste au regard de l'effort
global de l'état au profit des
collectivités puisqu'il représente 2 626
milliards d'euros d'autorisations
d'engagement et deux virus 580 milliards
d'euros de crédit tellement de
11 mais je vais vous prouver que même
sur cette mission budgétaire
l'immobilisme n'est pas de mise tout
d'abord l'article 92 du projet de loi de
finances prévoit de fusionner la
dotation globale d'équipement et la
dotation de développement rural pour
créer une nouvelle dotation d'équipement
des territoires ruraux
elle sera dotée de 615 millions d'euros
donc pas de diminution son
fonctionnement permettra d'améliorer de
simplifier la gestion
ces crédits déconcentrés au niveau des
préfectures d'élargir le champ des
projets éligibles et donc de mieux
répondre aux besoins des territoires
ruraux notamment pour le montage de
projets conformes aux attentes exprimées
par les collectivités territoriales
lors des assises des territoires ruraux
deuxièmement par ailleurs quelques
dotations sont abondés afin de répondre
à des besoins spécifiques
c'est le cas de la dotation spéciale de
construction d'équipement des
établissements scolaires de mayotte ou
encore du fonds de soutien communes
touchées par le redéploiement
territorial des armées qui progressent
respectivement de 5 et 10 millions
d'euros
enfin la dotation de développement
urbain est reconduite sur l'ensemble de
la période 2011 2013 et l'état
continuera ainsi d'apporter son soutien
aux projets dans le domaine économique
et sociale des communes les plus
défavorisés telles sont les principales
orientations dont je voulais vous faire
part avant de répondre de façon un peu
plus complète à des interventions mais
elle était tellement nombreuses en
termes de questions posées que je vais
essayer de prendre quelques
interrogations générique si vous voulez
bien ça me permettra de respecter autant
que possible monsieur le président le
timing total qui m'est donnée tout
d'abord revenons sur la situation
difficile nous le savons tous mes chers
collègues la situation dans notre pays
est difficile elle est difficile dans
d'autres pays
nous avons tous les jours quasiment des
renseignements qui nous viennent de la
situation fragile que nous pouvons
connaître par exemple pour l'irlande
médias pas que l'irlande
vous le savez bien et dans cette
situation que l'effort fasse un effort
que l'état fasse l'effort c'est normal
que les collectivités participent au
même titre c'est normal aussi
on ne peut pas attendre autre chose nous
ne serions pas responsable il si nous ne
faisions pas par contre évidemment il
faut tenir compte de la situation
spécifique des collectivités
territoriales il ne s'agit pas de fermer
les yeux
il ne s'agit pas de détourner la tête
mais que les collectivités participent
c'est normal c'est le premier point le
deuxième point la taxe professionnelle
on y reviendra d'ici la fin de semaine
ou début de semaine prochaine
mais quand même tous ceux qui m'ont
expliqué que dorénavant
à partir de la taxe professionnelle la
situation pour les collectivités et
terriblement dégradée
bien sûr que nous n'avons plus les mêmes
marges de manoeuvre c'est tout à fait
juste
mais pour autant permettez moi de dire
que et de répéter que en réalité la
contribution que les collectivités ont
plus de la part de l'état non seulement
a été au même niveau et ça c'était la
garantie qui a été prise mais elle a été
dépassée de 1,1 milliard en 2010 par
rapport à ce qui était prévu en 2009
donc arrêtons de dire moi j'avais
entendu au congrès des maires à mr était
intervenu pour dire qu'il a une baisse
de 50 % de la dotation
c'est pas possible on appris la garantie
qu'il y aurait au moins le maintien
en réalité au total y à 1,1 milliard de
plus donc ça ne veut pas dire que tout
est simple ça ne veut pas dire notamment
que bien sûr nous n'avons pas perdu en
termes de marge de manoeuvre au niveau
du financier dans les collectivités
mais la réalité c'est que au minimum
nous avons eu la même dotation que par
le passé en réalité avec 20 milliards de
plus
troisième chose monsieur le président
pons les mets ont d'autres ont évoqué la
même question excusez moi de vous
répondre de façon plus directe la
situation des départements c'est clair
qu'au niveau des départements
nous avons véritablement l'effet de
ciseau avec une dépense qui continuent
notamment dans le domaine du social en
particulier pour la question de la
dépendance et en même temps les
ressources elle évolue beaucoup plus
difficilement avec en particulier les
droits de mutation qui à un moment donné
avait complètement plongé dans cette
situation la première réponse sera
effectivement une réponse de deux
dotations pour permettre d'accompagner
les départements qui sont dans la
situation les plus fragiles mais surtout
la deuxième question au delà de la
question des normes c'est d'accompagner
les départements au niveau de la
dépendance ce grand chantier sera lancé
nous le savons bien le ministre a été
chargé d'ores et déjà de réfléchir et ça
se fera avec les collectivités et
notamment bien sûr les départements
parce que le problème est là moi je me
souviens quand j'étais président de
conseil général quand nous avons discuté
de la pas ici mes chers collègues ici à
l'époque nous avions demandé à ce qu au
niveau de la pas 50 % de la dépense soit
compensée par l'état 50%
le gouvernement de l'époque c'était
monsieur j'ose pas permettez-moi de le
dire a refusé de fixer la norme à 50%
aujourd'hui on voudrait qu'on fasse la
dotation totale
soyons raisonnables ce n'est pas
possible c'est totalement juste c
c'est ici que ça s'est passé j'étais
dans l'ain j'étais dans l'enceinte quand
ça s'est passé permettez moi de le
redire c'est la réalité
pour autant pour autant pour autant je
vous permets de dire monsieur chers
collègues sur président vous prendrez
les débats ici et vous retrouvez que
nous avons demandé 50 cent et le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu le mettre
dans la loi parce qu'il savait très bien
que la dépense irait en grandissant
ça c'est la réalité je vais vous de
sortir alors ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ne faut tourner la tête
j'ai bien compris soyez assuré que le
gouvernement va ouvrir ce débat parce
que nous savons bien que c'est là dessus
que se pose la question le gouvernement
à l'époque ne l'avait pas fait c'est pas
pour autant que nous ne devons pas le
faire demain
c'est donc nous allons ouvrir ce
chantier mon cher collègue la troisième
le quatrième point que je voudrais
évoquer évidemment c'est celui du
cinquième risque
j'en ai parlé un instant c'est ça la
vraie question que nous avons là ensuite
sur le rôle du comité des finances
locales
cher monsieur là à porter j'ai bien noté
que nous ne souhaitons pas voir sa
disparition son rôle de s'amenuiser
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
travailler en particulier au niveau de
la dotation de solidarité rurale où il
aura un vrai rôle cinquièmement les
critères de bonne gestion
il ne s'agit évidemment pas de dire
voilà les bons gestionnaires voilà des
mauvais gestionnaires par contre comme
les dotations la plupart du temps c'est
simplement la reprise des dépenses
quelle que soit la façon dont les
dépenses ont été calculés ceux qui hier
avait fait des efforts en matière de
taxe professionnelle au niveau des taux
eh bien ils sont handicapés puisque
l'état compense même lorsque les taux de
taxe professionnelle était élevée même
lorsqu'à l'époque les régions certaines
régions avaient augmenté d'une année à
l'autre de 80% la fiscalité l'état
compense mais je crois qu'à un moment
donné il est normal qu'il y ait une
marge de discussions entre les uns et
les autres il ne s'agit pas de décerner
des prix mais il s'agit d'avoir un
moment des discussions sur la base de
critères concernent nous pour mettre en
place sixièmement au niveau de
l'autonomie fiscale et financière par
rapport aux recettes c'est clair qu'avec
la réforme telle qu'elle est passée
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
a baissé après la réforme au niveau des
régions on est entre 8 à 10% de la
maîtrise sur les recettes au niveau des
départements de 12 à 20 % au niveau des
communes aux alentours de 40%
en moyenne c'est clair ça a baissé mais
je rappelle aussi mes chers collègues
notamment en allemagne
c'est pas tellement les recettes dont
ils ont la marche où ils ont les marges
de manoeuvre c'est sur les dépenses et
si je prends les dépenses une étude a
été faite au niveau de la mission
d'inspection igf iga et bien cela montre
que les ratios d'autonomie financière
dépenses sur les suivantes pour les
régions 2011 55 29 % contre 47 % en 2003
pour les départements 67%
aujourd'hui contre 58 6% en 2003 pour
les communes 63 7% contre 70 8 % en 2003
c'est à dire qu'au niveau des dépenses
l'autonomie pour ce qui n'est pas des
dépenses obligatoires a progressé depuis
cette période
eh bien je souhaite elle dire parce que
bien sûr il est important de parler des
recettes mais aussi des dépenses êtes
bien compris
monsieur le président que mon temps
était passé c'est raison pour laquelle
je vais conclure pour dire que notamment
pour ce qui concerne le décret pour les
élections au niveau de la commission
départementale et bien dès que nous
aurons le retour au niveau du conseil
constitutionnel
nous allons mettre en route une
proposition décret qui devait aller au
conseil d'état tels que nous aurons le
retour évidemment ce devrait être au
début du mois de janvier
nous ferons parvenir pour mettre tous la
route mais dès le mois de décembre nous
contacterons les préfectures pour que
cela soit m soit mise en place au niveau
des relations avec les collectivités
mesdames et messieurs je répondrais de
façon plus complète tout à l'heure lors
des amendements pour permettre d'avoir
le la vision globale sur l'ensemble des
questions qui étaient soumises vous
remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
intervention cette bonne augure bastia
du tonus en tout cas espérons que alors
mes chers collègues j'ai le très grand
plaisir au nom du sénat tout entier de
saluer la présence dans notre tribune
officielle de van hamme rossana bol du
président de la commission des affaires
européennes du sénat italien
madame la présidente bold et est une
élue du piémont une région frontalière
de la france surtout de la savoie et
elle nous fait l'honneur d'être
parfaitement francophone et j'ai pu le
constater pendant les commentaires tout
à l'heure madame la présidente est
accompagné de notes excellentes collègue
jean bizet président de la commission
des affaires européennes du sénat
nous sommes particulièrement sensibles à
l'intérêt et la sympathie que notre
collègue porte à notre institution et
surtout au développement de la
coopération entre le panais madame et
notre sénat spécialement dans les
affaires européennes
nous avons à nous rapprocher pour mettre
en oeuvre le traité de rome au nom du
sénat de la république française je
forme des voeux pour que son séjour en
france contribue à renforcer les liens
de notre amitié transalpine au sein de
l'europe et je souhaite en votre nom
la plus cordiale bienvenue
bien mes chers collègues nous allons
procéder à l'examen des amendements
portant sur les crédits de la mission
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
figurant à l'état b article 48 étape et
un amendement 240 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
pour défendre votre amant
oui monsieur le président mes chers
collègues il s'agit tout simplement d'un
amendement qui majorent les crédits
d'émission relations collectives d'été
rituel pour compenser aux collectivités
territoriales se forme de crédits
budgétaires dgd principalement plusieurs
transferts de compétences ne pouvant
être compensées se forme de thé ip p il
vise ajuster les montants des droits à
compensation pour 2011 en fonction
données dont le gouvernement ne
disposait pas lors du dépôt du plf 2011
et dont la plupart d'entre eux sont
définitifs et ont été validés par la
commission consultative sur l'évaluation
des charges comme chaque année le
gouvernant présente donc au moment de la
discussion au sénat
les derniers ajustements nécessaires au
vu des données disponibles
en réalité il s'agit tout simplement de
dotations supplémentaires que je vous
propose
quel est l'avis du rapporteur massive ce
président il s'agit d'un amendement qui
tire les conséquences de données dans le
gouvernement disposez pas lors du dépôt
du présent projet de loi et il permet de
dégager 6689 838 euros sur la dgt c'est
donc une bonne nouvelle donc favorable
bien
le pape demande de parole le sénat est
d'accord pour adopter ce d'amendements
240 pas d'avis contraire pas
d'opposition abstention groupe crc
abstention autrement à l'unanimité nous
allons procéder au vote des crédits de
la mission relations avec les
collectivités territoriales figurant à
l'étape et j'ai été saisi d'aucune
demande de parole d'explications de vote
avant l'expiration du délai limite je
vais donc on voit les crédits de la
mission
ceux qui sont favorables veulent bien
levé la main avis contraire
alors avis contraire groupe socialiste
et groupe crc
les cadets sont adoptés maintenant mes
chers collègues nous allons procéder à
l'examen de l'amendement portant sur les
crédits du compte spécial avances aux
collectivités territoriales figurant à
l'état des à nager un amendement à
l'article 50 du rapporteur de la
commission des finances monsieur
reporter de la parole merci monsieur le
ministre
chaque avec depuis 96 aucune avance n'a
été attribuée à des collectivités
territoriales en application de
l'article 14 de la loi de décembre 46 et
donc nous proposons de supprimer ces
crédits compte tenu de cette absence
utilisation et c'est le but de cet
amendement qu'elle est là mais les
ministres le rapporteur viens de dire il
n'y a pas eu de consommation des crédits
peut imaginer que c'est parce que
peut-être parce que les taux de crédit
était particulièrement barre sur sur le
marché ça ne rend que prague l on n'est
pas sûr de ce qui va se passer dans les
années qui viennent
je m'en remets donc à la sagesse du
sénat je vous remercie ceux qui sont
favorables à un homme sur la lune sur
des finances de bien levé la main est ce
qu'il y a des avis contraire je n'en
vois pas d abstention sans doute donc
ces crédits sont supprimées et l'article
5 ans est ainsi modifié même vote je
suppose
il est adopté maintenant nous allons
procéder au crédit du compte spécial
avances aux collectivités territoriales
figurant à l'état d
j'ai été saisi d'aucune demande
explications de vote avant l'expiration
du délai je mets donc aux voix les
crédits de la mission
ceux qui sont pour les flammes un avis
contraire abstention ils sont adoptés
j'appelle en discussion les articles 79
à 86 et les amendements qui sont
rattachés pour leurs examens aux crédits
de la mission relations avec les
collectivités territoriales à l'article
je n'ai pas d'amendement il est donc
même quand il est adopté
à l'article 80 g un amendement de
monsieur d'allier à bazeilles prescrit
trop tard maintenant donc la parole est
à moi monsieur le président je m'excuse
mais j'ai demandé s'ils avaient des
paroles il y en avait pas non mais il
n'y a pas de paroles d'inscrites
alors monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise que j'ai cosigné
avec notre collègue jean jacques jégou
vise à prolonger d'une année et d'une
année seulement je vous rassure monsieur
le ministre
un dispositif que la haute assemblée
avait adopté il ya deux ans afin de ne
pas trop pénaliser un certain nombre de
communes moins d'une trentaine des
communes dont le potentiel financier est
nettement inférieur à la moyenne de
leurs strates puisque je crois que le
seuil avait été fixé à plus de 20% en
dessous de la moyenne de la strate et
ses communes s'étaient vu pénalisé par
le changement du mode de recensement de
la population par l'insee ces communes
avaient en effet en 2005 et 2006 réalisé
des recensement complémentaire
on avait alors des comptes et pour
celles ci une augmentation de la
population supérieure à 15%
et donc cette population avait été prise
en compte et puis le mode de changement
de calcul de l'insee tout d'un coup
avait fait disparaître cette population
et donc les dotations de ces
collectivités était sensé effectivement
diminué dans quand il y a deux ans nous
avions exposé ce problème la haute
assemblée sur un avis favorable du
gouvernement avait adopté ce dispositif
transitoire pour deux années nous vous
demandons de le prolonger d'une année
sachant que statistiquement il faut en
fait 5 ans pour ce que ces communes
retrouve la population qu'elle avait
décompté antérieurement donc voilà une
demande qui me semble raisonnable qui
coupe un peu la poire en deux et qui
pourrait effectivement permettre
d'atténuer les difficultés de ces
communes
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
merci au président c'est un moment été
évoquée par monsieur jégo en commission
des finances
dès l'examen de la première partie son
coût serait très limité sans doute moins
d'un million d'euros et il a été gagée
par la commission des finances grâce aux
prélèvements effectués sur le phare eu
en direction de la dgf donc nous
souhaiterions néanmoins avoir des
informations du gouvernement bien
monsieur le ministre votre avis s'il
vous plaît chers collègues je ne sais
pas si si chacun a bien compris qu est
ce qui s'est passé c'est que jusqu'à
présent on fait les les recensements
tous les six ans avec de temps en temps
quand il y avait de fortes croissances
dans les communes un recensement
complémentaire
les nouvelles modalités c'est des
recensements quasi permanent
l'ajustement permanent
du nombre d'habitants dans les communes
ce qui s'est passé c'est que lorsqu'on
faisait des recensement complémentaire
en fonction de l'accroissement de
logements on attribue en moyenne quatre
habitants par logement et lorsque les
ressources ont été faits lorsque on a
pris les chiffres on s'est rendu compte
qu'il n'avait pas quatre habitants par
logement et donc cela tout simplement a
fait en sorte qu'on a constaté qu'il y
avait moins d'habitants que la réalité
c'est là que nos collègues ont déposé
l'amendement dix ans il y a deux ans bah
écoutez il est moins de population que
la réalité
donc on prend en compte la réalité pour
tous les aides mais pour ceux qui
avaient fait sept
ce recensement complémentaire on leur
donne le temps de s'adapter puisque en
réalité il aurait droit à moins que ce
qu'ils ont perçu
on a accepté de donner deux ans les deux
ans ont passé
il souhaite qu'on redonne deux ans plus
un en plus bas au niveau du gouvernement
il faut savoir la chose suivante c'est
que si nous acceptons cela la diminution
du coût qui est impliquée ici bien ça va
en défaveur tout simplement de la
péréquation soyons clairs la deuxième
chose c'est que nous appliquerions tout
simplement les mêmes principes qui sont
appliqués à l'ensemble des communes sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
donc c'est une exception au principe tel
qu'il est indiqué et et en même temps
dernière chose avec l'augmentation très
forte de la têt sujet l'a dit tout à
l'heure 70 5 millions d'euros dans un
contexte de finances publiques très
difficile et bien cela devrait puisque
ce sont des communes théoriquement
contexte financier difficile permettre
de compenser la perte qu'il y aurait au
niveau de cette non reconduite d'une
mesure ancien ça permettra une
compensation au titre de la dsi si fait
que normalement la problématique qu'elle
est énoncée devrait trouver une solution
la raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
est défavorable
voilà donc pour le budget de cet après
midi est consacré aux relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire le journal de
19 heures présenté par michel grossiord
puis le 22 heures sonia mabrouk
pour retrouver toutes les séances en vod
rendez vous sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur notre chaîne à 19
heures on se retrouve